hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Seibert
today we're gonna check out the e3 2015
trailer for hitman I didn't know we were
doing this oh yeah knows this is the gun
thing kind of like Charlie's Angels I'm
Cameron Diaz by the way
oh my Lucy Liu yeah you look like a Lucy
Liu Ted Alissa's Bill Murray your brain
mac memory is this a reboot we're giving
to a point in games where we were
getting to like hit Matt like 6 & 7
we're getting to these higher numbers
and a lot of games have just decided to
lose the number all together in the gist
salic it's very confusing it very good
it is but you know Xbox named their new
console Xbox one so I don't know people
don't know what they're doing
I can tell there's gonna be a cool
trailer yeah she just looks really good
these tanks oh wow dear whoa the cow
real everything looks is Walter White
[Music]
damn snow particles man
[Music]
[Music]
just the fabric alone
[Music]
do you great soundtrack I know they plug
this out
[Music]
[Music]
they say he was going to 100 kilometers
like I don't think he was going that
fast I can keep ran that far oh wow
agent 47 cool looks good you know that
has got to be I've seen a lot of these
e3 trailers that has got to be one of
the most stylistic ones I've seen oh
yeah yeah with the graphics and the way
everything was cut the way they slice
all the footage together the soundtrack
that was just a really good trailer and
dude if the gameplay just looks like
even a little bit like that
yeah yeah cinematics McKay brigitta look
amazing December huh it's not too far
from now no well there was quite a few
games at e3 there was just like things
that are coming out here soon yeah yeah
yeah I like the way he used the gun at
the ending it was like sideways like
Click Clack [ __ ] and then boom
my name is hitman agent 47 just a [ __ ]
just every now and then you need to go
do what yeah yeah so [ __ ] and then boom
and he catches the bullets
now it's [ __ ] cool I hope you can run
that fast in the game you know those
graphics are just [ __ ] amazing I
wonder what the gameplay is gonna look
like I mean that's the thing is like
there's quite a bit of trailers that
came out on a three that are cinematic
and of course like you can't really tell
yeah how exactly it's gonna look because
I mean watchdogs everything we'd seen at
e3 up until the game's release was like
this looks amazing like that it's so
detailed all that's where stuff and then
like they dumped it down and everyone's
kind of like what happened if they stay
true if they keep pushing yeah people I
do gotta say I just saw the hitman agent
47 movie trailer people are really
complaining how it looks nothing like
the video game and just based off tone
and style from this one trailer alone I
could see why people are disappointed
because the movie looks like just a fun
action Rob but this looks like there's
actual like dark tone it's real style
more than just like yeah that's actually
game like it looks like there's actual
legit content hey you know right oh I
mean the thing is that making a video
game movie is hard yeah because you're
taking something that's interactive and
making it not interactive yeah and it's
like hours and hours of gameplay too and
you crush it down into two hours yeah I
just watched a game theory they're
awesome if you haven't checked them out
a bat pad he's great but he did a whole
uh he did two part video like a two part
series I'm like why video games don't
make good movies hmm it's really
interesting because you do was like you
have this very interactive thing you
shape the story and then you're just
kind of sitting idly watching this thing
going like yeah yeah hit man ran six
miles in 36 minutes I can do that I can
do that easily six miles in 36 minutes
six minutes per mile I can do it you
think oh yeah no problem
yeah no probably just keep throwing up
along the way oh yeah yeah no I run like
five minutes and I start puking and so
yeah I know I can do this I can do this
I'm gonna prove it I want to be him for
Halloween mache my head completely bald
yeah oh my god click-clack [ __ ]
also real quick the guy with the wine he
put the poison in the wine and then he
drank the poisoned wine I mean you know
sup yeah or at least that's what I
gathered I'm confused I'm confused too
and there's not enough hot videogame
[ __ ] in this trailer Jesus there
should be more hot videogame [ __ ] oh
guys the technical term right yep
technical term hot videogame [ __ ]
mm-hmm they don't require a personnel no
no anyway guys thanks for tuning into
the real rejects if you're new to this
channel you can subscribe and you can
check out damns gaming channel if you
haven't seen yet scald that cyber
channel you can check it out and
subscribe if you like it and you can
follow us on facebook instagram twitter
and vine mmm where if we get more
followers more product placement yeah
Full Sail University it's a good school
sharknado 3 it's awesome
you just toss them like 2 2 freebies I
know don't get away yourself for free
you're better than that most dangerous
town good documentary what that's 3 yeah
I got 3 so far
looking for a fourth